With what's going on in our society,
with women and the autonomy of their bodies,
it's important that art reflects life.
It's an honor to get to explore this story
because I know hard conversations have to be had
surrounding missing women
and human trafficking.
You don't hear about it.
You don't read about it.
The rape, murder, and trafficking
of black and brown girls
has never been anyone's priority,
ever, in any capacity.
Gabrielle, she is an advocate
for survivors of sexual trauma.
She's very outspoken about
her own past with sexual trauma.
And I think she really relied on
the strength and the pain
that she's had to grapple with.
My story is pretty well known.
I've been talking about it
for the last 25 years.
I was raped and beaten
at 19 in the Bay Area.
A lot of the locations are very familiar.
A lot of the situations are very familiar.
I've had 30 years to intimately understand
sexual violence against black and brown girls
and how we are...
systemically ignored
and blamed for our own trauma.
She brought a grit and a fire.
She's brilliant.
But I know it also cost her.
You are doing a lot of good in this world.
Well I want to do more.
I need to do more.
The thing about trauma is it's not linear.
And surviving and healing is not linear.
We really pull back the curtain on
how a girl becomes groomed,
how she's trafficked,
and the aftermath.
The attempts to reclaim your life.
Season three is so full of deep heartbreak,
courage,
and also triumph of the human spirit.
It's looking at the
juxtaposition between
the way the police, the media, and the government
respond to young white women,
and the way they respond
to minority groups.
The fact that they are being left behind.
It's really tied to something happening in Oakland,
happening in our country, and in our world.
Where we can highlight an issue
that people were not talking about,
that they really should be.
We need you to put pressure
on the police department
to bring these girls home.
They're real circumstances
that people are living every day.
And if we can shine
a light on this subject,
maybe we can save a life.
It's taken me 30 years to unpack.
And through this show,
and hopefully through me and my history,
we can give it the large platform
and the attention it deserves.
It feels like we are fighting
for our very breath,
our very life.
Because there's legit women,
and girls, and boys
hanging in the balance.
It's that important.
The work that we're doing,
season three is that important.
And everyone understood the assignment.
My name is Poppy Scoville,
and I need you to reconsider.
You have no idea what that little thing
can mean to a survivor.